welcome to this video playing Frankie J
from the US and if i'm not mistaken on
the skies also doing videos on the games
i recently had a game against him and
someone pointed out in the comment
section that he did the video on this as
well so but i'm not quite sure i think
it's on chest videos doc TV I'm not to
100% sure maybe the same guy that that
made this comment on the other video can
no can shed some light on this so we
have this ancient line the clothes droid
chigorin and play this line usually
associated with the Rubenstein yeah
Black has temporarily one upon because
94 94 24 the bishop is saying and now
his he's moving the bishop came on
Bishop to deem to be three hmm sure
at some point I play 97 and Bishop f6
and this in this line I wasn't so sure
about the exact timing I I went for it
immediately not not sure but with waseem
it's helping me to activate this this
Bishop on the other hand to the d5
square is a bit weak so must be cautious
okay let's go here I guess bb7 should be
the right place for for the bishop
attacking you form okay night h5 is a
possible idea yeah I'm wondering about
g6 should I play g62 yeah like I guess I
should spend the smooth yes I've got 95
or 95 yeah Bishop b5 looks looks
ridiculous ok ok but he's God works
ammonium maybe I should have done
something differently it's not like I'm
in trouble I don't think so Queen B 6 up
should be three years probably move he
wants to play it doesn't seem like I'm
in trouble but right now it feels like I
maybe could have done something
something better along the way
normally night f1 what you played and
move through it in giving up the spawn
temporarily shouldn't give white
anything I dear wider so what is
certainly fine fine I mean in the sense
of maybe it's better nothing too
dramatic but how well maybe a good idea
try to reroute our challenge on the D D
file if you now place 93 i'm going to
take play 93 and win the exchange so aha
interesting night I could play Knight c4
but these six hang services this is a
problem and in general if you place 93 I
can take to you can take it for you
important call it a point what if I on
the other hand if i play whoops if I of
trying to double and it should be three
but no Bishop e3 is not helping and I
can take take you for move tricky yeah
these kind of positions are always a
tricky to play this role Lopez open
center positions mmm it's always at
least for me I always think okay I'd
like to have a bit more time here to
figure out the complication this I think
is quite surprising that he that he
played an a piece to d5 and allow me to
capture so that the poor now emerges on
d5 I didn't expect that at all should
help me okay I need to get out of the
UFO
out of this pin I've maybe 93 rookie 791
I know it's even better this is a very
big very big Fork night night 8 x f4 all
pieces who came so if i take F for now
and she's playing nadji flight resign
and now he's resigning it I can take
just there for him it's easier even 94 I
can I can play yeah maybe even this move
immediately going here what this one if
I just want to protect it yeah he lost
the track here here here he needs to do
something else i'm not quite short the
position looks looks comfortable for
white it's got good pieces and then the
good idea to strengthen the position
maybe that one this is the calm
suggestion just piling up on the pond
are interesting yeah it wants to play
this one in order to answer bishop
reform with nigerian winning position
which i don't really understand that the
world okay all cats of stuff is hanging
i probably need to take understand that
queen bee 723 and no be 56 coming yeah
white was much better this is this is
clear and this really relieves lots of
pressure yeah 93 m this was already good
i was playing Queen B 7 to crooklyn
97-91 and this is very nice now because
um this is saying this is hanging and
there's this threat so you cannot let's
say go go here check because I'm picking
up the bishop and he needs to play some
retreating move with the rook this is
again 93 may be here and then I just I
just grabbed it yeah but this move in
fact won the game because he played 93
here it says it's probably probably
about equal I know something like this
protecting d5 and then yeah as they say
it's a game it just continues and it's a
fight not sure probably about equal
alright thanks for watching